following the settlement with Wayne Moe  what are some of the lessons that you've  learned and what is your relationship  now with Google or alphabet their parent  couple I think one of the lessons that  that we've learned and I bring to the  table is that this is a big industry  it's a six trillion dollar industry and  no company is going to make it alone  part of a settlement was rebuilding  trust rebuilding our relationship with  Google and way moe and what you see with  this uber elevate summit is that we are  bringing industry participants private  public regulators together in order to  push forward this technology in a truly  innovative way no company when it comes  to transportation which is such a big  sector can do it alone we want to be a  trailblazer but we want a trail blazed  with others along with us